I'm not sure how much longer the
experiment can go on experiment day 15
June 17 1945
[Music]
gentlemen the experiment is over we are
turning off the gas and opening the
chamber
stand back against the wall or you will
be shot upon examination you will be
freed no there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's the first episode of
2018 yeah it's hard to believe it's 2018
yeah Happy New Year everybody hope
everybody had a good one
yeah um since it's the new year you may
have noticed we made a couple of changes
I changed the theme song and if you're
watching us on YouTube I changed up you
know the the open air a little bit I
thought it was time to change that so I
mentioned it to Jenny and she came up
with that awesome song I said we need to
go with something a little more like
industrial sound well I didn't come up
with it I just got it off a free sound
and yeah but then you mixed it alternate
with your other things it sounds good
though yeah so that was one of the
changes we made I also happen to you'll
notice at the end of the show I have
like a new little ending theme we're
also gonna start putting all of our
patrons and supporters in the end
credits yeah on our YouTube show for the
audio I think I'll probably just put the
names in the description just so you
know it's it'll still be in there but
yeah if you're watching this on youtube
you'll see your name and the credits yes
you'll get a plug yeah and stuff like
that cuz you know I don't know why I
didn't think of doing that before but um
and we also decided that what we were
gonna do too and we had actually been
talking about doing this for awhile and
we only just now got around to doing it
was that aside from having you know the
main topic that we're gonna talk about
we're still gonna do we also decided to
do like a little extra mini topic that
was something that was like newer like a
weird thing that happened in the news or
happened recently or kind of like a
current of this yes like news yeah but
like still like a paranormal or like a
weird you know something like this I'm
weird goes down we're gonna mention it
right so just so we have like a little
mini thing that's something that's more
contemporary to go along with our main
topic so that's one of the changes that
we made also other than that just our
same regular plugs Oh check out our last
movie review which was the legacy if you
haven't seen that one and also don't
forget to check out our patreon which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
check out our
Blagh at 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there is a link in the
sidebar if you would rather give a
one-time donation through PayPal that
would be much appreciated and also I
forgot to do because usually I try to
set up Google Plus Google Hangouts for
the 10 dollar or not patrons and I
usually do it on the fourth weekend of
the month but I didn't that you know
that should have been last weekend and I
didn't really get my [ __ ] together so
and I forgot about it so probably we are
gonna do it this coming weekend so I'll
be sending invites out for $10 now
people if you would like to attend our
Google hangout hopefully we don't have
any technical issues we have been having
some technical issues on the last ones
and I had a couple people contact me
that they couldn't get through or they
couldn't or the link wasn't working or
something like that so hopefully that
will that will get worked out faceless
villain I'll tell you what that audio
book selling like crazy we don't know
where it's coming from
just yes if any of you guys have had
bought them thank you very much and yeah
that's pretty awesome yeah it's a it's
actually selling really well yeah and
codes are going out to you yes it codes
out yeah and I still have some so if you
do if you still want one then um you
know get in touch with me on Facebook or
email but you have my email address yeah
we'll send you free and I'll send you a
free one cuz I still have some also if
you would write a review I would really
appreciate it yeah okay I might also
want to make another announcement for
those of you who know know about the
math mountain poltergeist case that I
was involved with my uncle red who was
like one of the main witnesses in that
case has passed away yes he died a few
weeks ago yeah and I forgot to mention
it in the last week but plus I didn't
want to mention it too much on a movie
with retrospect yeah true that's more
suddenly but a regular episode yeah you
know he was only 61 years old and what
he was at his apartment with my aunt
Lois and he hadn't been feeling good and
just out of the blue he said Lois hand
me that I mean
a wet towel over here to wipe my
forehead and she said okay and she got
up and started heading towards it and
she as she was walking away he's like I
don't feel too good and she says what's
wrong because I don't know
don't call the don't call the paramedics
hey boom fell out of his chair never
woke back up yeah heart failure yep 61
years old yeah so you know my buddy
but you know yeah and like a lot of you
have have read the mammoth mountain
poltergeist or you know have listened to
our episode about it yeah and I was
gonna get a recording of all his
testimony too so we could make a show
about it yeah and have him on as a guest
but we still have Louis and we'll have
Louis on but Dan not only did I lose
Marco I lost one of my main witnesses in
that yeah and his testimony but we have
the book yes I mean at least we got that
because you know I do have like a lot of
quotes from him because he did write
something when I was doing the book and
Louis wrote some things he had said also
so at least we have that yeah I just
wanted a recording of it yeah and we'd
actually considered maybe going back to
Mammoth Mountain and finding that yeah
and I think we just mentioned that like
a couple episodes ago matter of fact
going back there yeah to that condo that
about a trip yeah yeah oh well yeah
that's what happens it's just like we
don't live forever why don't you kick
seeing this yeah you get you get to be
about 40 years old you realize we don't
live very long no we don't know five
years goes by fast now the older you get
I don't know how young some of you folks
are out there but this will happen to
you also the older you get the faster
time yeah I hit 30 now those man up and
becoming an old man Wow 35 no there's no
[ __ ] this isn't happening
pow 40 yeah I could believe it 30 to 40
goes by fast oh yeah
and it just seems to speed up more yeah
once you get into your forties but
what's funny is like from birth to 20
seems like that took forever yeah yeah
it's ridiculous now it is weird okay I
wanted to mention one of these things
that's been going on lately and then yes
this is art this is our mini current
event yeah we're talking about today yes
some cool [ __ ] happen recently yeah it's
called a tic-tac UFO yeah tell us about
Jenny okay so even though this news
story only came out recently like in the
past week or so it actually refers to
something that happened back in 2004
yeah we're just finding out and we're
only just finding out about now because
it was just Declassified in some way
that never danly it did show up on a
discussion board kind of like on the
dark web between fighter pilots they
were talking about it sure I have each
other and it did kind of leak out from
that time but the video isn't real
impressive if you don't understand the
context so it's been on the on the
internet for a long time and people
didn't really know what they were
looking at but it's been confirmed now
that this was a damn honor for
unidentified flying object yeah and
apparently this is like a super official
like this came right from the Pentagon
like the video and everything like that
Pentagon hired these subcontractors to
investigate these UFO sightings that
they were having with pilots and other
government aids yeah and evidently this
has been funded it was funded from 2007
I believe to 2012 and I think that the
that the program is still ongoing
although I don't think it's funded as
much um but so what evidently ended up
happening this happened in 2004 and the
main witness that most of the news
stories are concentrating on because
he's one of the main ones the main guys
that saw this although he's not the only
one that saw but he's kind of the main
one that they've been talking to he was
a US navy commander David framer and he
had been in the Navy for 18 years I
believe Wow at this stage so this
happened in November of 2004 and
evidently this guy raver was commanding
a Strike Fighter Squadron
yes f-18s yeah and they were doing an
exercise it was somewhere between like
San Diego and Ensenada Mexico yeah I
think it was like 200 miles off the
coast of San Diego yeah and this was
before they were going to be deployed to
the Persian Gulf now while they were
doing this exercise he gets an order to
do what they call real-world tasking
like
or something you have to go check out
yeah so he says that the command told
him that there were some unidentified
flying objects and they were going from
80,000 feet down to 20,000 feet and then
disappearing and he said that the
commanding officer had told him that
they had been tracking these objects for
several weeks at this point and they
didn't know what they were yes so they
wanted this squadron to go check it out
yeah no there's something that's kind of
been left out already he wasn't the
first person to see this no the message
that he got actually came from the
report of an AWACS aircraft that was in
that area that picked it up on radar and
looked at it and what the what the AWACS
pilots saw was some kind of disturbance
in the water without with an object kind
of hovering right above it and then he
gets the message to go down there and go
look at it because the AWACS might have
turned away from it and went back to the
you know the ship yeah towards the ship
so evidently they could they get there
they see this object that's flying
around a patch of water in the ocean and
he describes it as a 40-foot tic-tac
looking object yes it didn't have any
wings or anything like that
yeah about the size of the school bus
yeah and underneath it he saw a
disturbance in the water and of our ship
went down it so he said that was the
closest thing he economy yes oh she ate
that although he did say that the object
wasn't causing any rotor wash no so
evidently so he gets he tries to get
closer to whatever this object is and
then he says he's starting to he's kind
of starting to close in on it it
accelerates and just like kind of
disappears he's like faster than he's
ever seen it he's like faster than it
should have been possible yeah ago yeah
he was flying he was flying towards it
he looks down on it and he had a wingman
with him and he started to actually
descend and he did this by circling down
in other words spinning and keeping it
off to his right and evidently this
tic-tac shaped object matched his turn
so constantly stayed on his left side
and rose up at the same time so in other
words he was doing a corkscrew down and
then the tic-tac object was doing a
corkscrew turn up it was a trip yes it
was like
sort of matching his right his
tournaments yeah and they he actually
has IR video infrared video of this
object and you can see it on you yeah
although I don't think like it's not
super clear like from the article but I
don't think he's the one that took the
video I think that he saw it and then he
went back to the aircraft carrier which
was the USS Nimitz and then there was
another crew that went to look for it
and they tracked it for a couple of
minutes I think they were the ones that
actually videotaped it yeah so it wasn't
just him that saw yeah you hear I'm
talking about it go look at that thing
look at it you know oh it's turning and
it's kind of like a diamond shaped
tic-tac
that's kind of rotating up on its edge
it's it's a strange looking thing
yeah now you're not really seeing the
surface of the craft you're at you're
basically just seeing its heat signature
so it's not a color image it's just kind
of like a bright white tin rack looking
ding yeah on a black and white
background it's hard to tell what you're
looking at now the video does not show
it taking off evidently they didn't
release that part of the video and this
government agency is still has a lot of
video classified that they evidently are
gonna release slowly over time which
that's a trip and this agency did a
whole analysis on it and verified you
know its its speed and how fast it took
off and where it was and all the witness
and they did say that this thing was
probably an extraterrestrial craft if so
so well and that's definitely what this
particular guy commander favorite that's
what he believed he's retired now he
retired from the Navy a couple years
later in 2006 and he says that he didn't
really tell anyone about it he said he
kind of you know got a ribbing from the
other guys that hadn't seen it and stuff
like that but he's like nothing really
came out of it until about 2009 and
there was a government official who he
didn't say who it was but he said they
were doing an unofficial investigation
later on a guy named Luis Elizondo who
was an intelligence officer who used to
work for the government but now he has a
private company that's called to this I
believe it's called to the stars Academy
of Arts and Sciences and they're kind of
trying to promote he's kind of a
consultant there where they're trying to
kind of promo
research into UFOs both first scientific
and entertainment purposes it's so um
evidently this Elizondo guy was the guy
that actually secured the release of
these videos from the Pentagon from this
apparently secret program that nobody
knew about but some of it's been
declassified now yeah and it confirms a
lot of things that I've constantly said
I've been suspected for a long time
right so that project Bluebook may have
ended but the government's interest in
these objects never ended the area
actually the Senator Harry Reid he's
retired now but he the Democratic
senator from Nevada was actually the guy
that started this particular program and
he has actually come out and said you
know it was one of the best things he
did and stuff cuz he's always been
interested in in this type of thing not
just from a scientific standpoint and
also from a defense military standpoint
to just trying to check out what this
was and you know that they are needed to
be more research into it so whether I
don't know if the program is still
ongoing some people say it is it
probably it probably is but I don't
think it's it's as funded as it was
until it confirms a lot of my suspicions
that they know about that these she
confirms a lot of my suspicions that
they know about these things
I don't think that they talked to these
UFOs I don't believe that I don't
believe that they've ever had
communication with these UFOs I believe
that they just see them I mean they know
it's some kind of an extraterrestrial
craft there's nothing they can do about
it I mean I'd be willing to think that
they're probably I you know like I said
I don't think I'm not one of those like
conspiracy theory people that are like
they're talking to aliens I don't I
think that every now and then they see
some kind of thing that it's possible it
could be extraterrestrial but they don't
know what it is right they don't know
how to communicate with it they just see
it and they're like okay well there's
that well just think about all they can
do about it just because they're
investigating them that basically proves
that they're not talking with ya because
if they were talking with him they
wouldn't know yeah I mean we know what
was going on they wouldn't be interested
in studying them right because the
aliens would answer their questions yeah
so that means that they know that these
aliens are coming here the aliens aren't
talking to us we're trying to figure out
more and the reason why I believe that
they know is because for years from
military guys
sent these reports up the chain of
command and these reports were never
punished i'm ex-army
i know that if i ever put up a report
that wasn't believed you'd be punished
they would say oh you're sending up a
false report you're crazy
that kind of thing and they punish you
but the Air Force has been putting these
things up an army put these reports into
the chain of command and send them
upwards and there's never any kind of
response that ends that they believe
that report but they don't know what to
do it they don't know okay well if they
didn't believe that report there'd be a
huge investigation they try to figure
out who caused this hoax a lot of guys
would be demoted maybe even our the
Corps Morpheus you can't do that kind of
military yeah so they believe these
reports now I'm looking at this craft
it's the size of a school bus I'm
thinking surprise some kind of an AI
drone and in you know extraterrestrial
drone or maybe it's uh maybe the aliens
themselves are some kind of a
intelligent machines you know there's no
proof that there's any biology because
the chief forces would have been
fantastic but then again he knows their
engineering may be so advanced that
they're yeah I mean there would really
be no way of knowing if especially if
they were that far in advance of us
right it's like they might be doing [ __ ]
that we haven't even [ __ ] thought of
what's weird those whenever cops or
military report these things these
crafts are doing pretty mundane [ __ ]
hovering above water shooting lights
down or sending the little balls of
light around church steeples like in you
pond you know then in the French Belgian
wave and you know or they're hovering
down by the ocean and they were in that
area because evidently they were picking
this this object up for several days
yeah and on so that's kind of boring
tedious kind of duty for a UFO you dig
yeah I was thinking that maybe it might
be some kind of a drone yeah it probably
is I'm like I just don't think I don't
know if there are aliens I don't think
there is interested in us as we think
they probably should pick yeah yeah it's
probably just like a routine checking
out there checking out environmental
factors and things like that you would
think that they would send a robotic
ship some kind of it yeah it's like why
would they even bother like sending any
of their like Pierrot quote-unquote here
probably just some fat weird
survey thing looking at the ocean yeah
that's probably all it is and like I
said I do 99 times out of 100 people
that say they see UFOs I think it's
[ __ ] yeah yeah well I think it's
it's just something that's like a normal
thing that they're misidentifying but
even Mitchell Kaku said you cannot
disregard all these all these yeah but
they're Leterrier yes there are a
handful that are probably legit times
like I said probably extraterrestrial I
don't know yeah I think everything else
is kind of eliminated yeah what else
could it be
yeah that's exactly ok so now that we've
kind of covered the our current event
for the week let's get into our main
topic now this was actually I can't
remember who suggested it but this was
actually a listener submission and they
wanted us to do a show on the Russian
sleep experiment yeah now this is a very
very infamous story yeah I came across
it a few years back and I have seen it
touted as true in a lot of places and
it's kind of like I don't know I just
cleverly written it is I find it a very
it's a fascinating story yeah and I can
see why people might think it's true
but I don't think it is ok I'm pretty
sure it's not as a writer you can see
the signatures over yeah yeah fictional
tale right ok so basically here's how it
goes at some time in the late 1940s the
real year or date is never given there
was a group of Russian scientists and
associated with the military and they
were going to do this experiment now
it's not super clear if the experiment
was to determine the effect of this
particular quote-unquote stimulant gas
or if it was to study the effect of
extreme sleep deprivation because both
of those things were happening in this
experiment ok so the researchers take
five guys their political prisoners and
they said ok so we're gonna take these
five guys and we're going to seal them
in a room for 30 days was how long it
was supposed to
we're going to fill this chamber with
debt this stimulant gas it's
experimental and we're going to monitor
them and see if they can stay awake for
30 days on this gas there's food in
there
there's cots in there at the end of the
experiment if they agree to the
experiment then they will be released so
they take these five guys and they seal
them in this room now they don't have
this is the 40s so they don't have you
know closed-circuit cameras or anything
like that the only way they can monitor
them is they have these kind of porthole
type windows that they can look in and
see them they have an oxygen gauge that
shows them how much oxygen they're using
so the guys are put in there and they're
watching them now for the first four or
five days nothing terribly untoward
seems to be happening but guys don't
seem to have much trouble staying awake
the only thing that seems strange is
that as the time goes on they start
talking about more and more like
traumatic incidents like at first
they're just kind of shooting the [ __ ]
of being regular but you know as the
days go on they start talking about
worse and worse things like it their
past and stuff like that but they didn't
really complain about anything about you
know cuz they'd been in prison before so
I guess this was kind of a step up and
so after about the fifth day they start
acting super paranoid and then there are
also microphones inside the thing so the
researchers can monitor what they're
talking about and stuff like that I
forgot to mention that so after about
the fifth day they start getting really
paranoid and they stop talking to each
other there however they start
whispering into the microphones and
coming up to the windows and like
talking like they're trying to talk to
the researchers yeah what the
researchers are trying to determine is
that it seems like the prisoners are
thinking like that they'll get special
treatment if they sell out the other
prisoners right so you know like I said
at first they seemed like they were kind
of hanging
there were buds and everything but now
they're trying to like narc on each
other and stuff like that because they
think that's gonna earn them brownie
points or something so the researchers
are just kind of like observing this and
everything like that they said they
don't know if this is really an
effective the gas or if isn't effect the
sleep deprivation or whatever because
these guys have not slept for five days
at this point now the next major thing
that happened happened on the ninth day
on the ninth day one of the dudes
started screaming and he just screamed
and screamed and screamed for three
hours straight running up and down in
the cell yeah and he screamed until
evidently he tore his vocal cords
oh goodness after a while he was still
trying to scream but could only produce
a sort of squeaking sound so the
researchers were not going into the cell
at this point so they were just seeing
through the windows and they were
listening to the microphones and so they
assumed well he must have torn his vocal
cords because he can't scream anymore so
they said now the weird thing about this
this guy is like screaming and running
up and down for three hours and the
other four prisoners do not react at all
okay they're just kind of sitting there
going okay they just sit there they're
just whispering into the microphones
like they had been doing like it wasn't
even happening and then a couple of the
other prisoners that weren't screaming
they had some books in the in the cell
like for entertainment and stuff like
that they started tearing the pages out
of the books
smearing them with their own [ __ ] and
pasting them over the porthole windows
yeah so that the researchers couldn't
see in any okay okay now after that
happened like after they pasted all the
windows when the researchers couldn't
see them the screaming stopped
yeah because one of the other guys
answered is framing too and also the
whispering into the microphones up so
it's just silence it okay now see this
is what this is the point at which I'm
kind of like okay because if they were
really doing an experiment yeah and the
guys like pieces you couldn't see in
there
they would stop and see what the [ __ ] is
going on in there right but they didn't
do that okay so they don't know what's
going on in there now okay now they said
that they were still looking at the
oxygen monitors and stuff like that so
they knew that the guys were still alive
in there yeah because they were still
using you know the same amount of oxygen
that five guys would use but they the
researchers are confused because the
microphones are all still on and they're
evidently still working yeah but they
don't hear anything and they say that's
very strange that there's five guys in
there doing it allegedly still alive and
they're not making any noise whatsoever
okay so at this point actually let me um
take a break right now because we're
just about at the halfway point and then
we'll get back and we'll get into the
the end of this story cuz it's pretty
good at power okay I'm already called
[ __ ]
okay so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we're back talking about the Russian
sleep experiment so they've been quiet
in there for yeah they've been very
quiet in there and like I said the
researchers are still looking at these
oxygen monitors and the oxygen monitors
not only showed that the five guys are
still alive that are still in there but
they're using as much oxygen as five
guys going through very strenuous
exercise would be using they're using a
lot of oxygen okay even though they
don't hear anything all right
so finally they let this go on until the
14th today okay
at which point they're like okay now we
have to figure out what the hell is
going on in there right yeah and so all
the windows are [ __ ] closed it with
[ __ ] paper with [ __ ] paper right I got
it so the researcher announces into the
microphone because they have not spoken
to the test subjects at any point until
now so he says into the microphone
there's an intercom inside the cell he
says we're opening the chamber to test
the microphones please step away from
the door lie flat on the floor or you'll
be shot and then no they're not sleeping
I don't know but then II says compliance
will earn one of you your immediate
freedom all right now at this point a
single calm voice comes through the
microphone hmm one of the guys inside
says we no longer want to be freed okay
okay yeah which that's creepy right yeah
that's creepy so evidently the
researchers don't know what to do with
this information so they're talking and
then like there's military guys there
because they're in on this too and
they're like well what do we do they
don't want to be let out and it's not
gonna you know [ __ ] so evidently they
argue for like a day or so because they
don't end up opening the chamber until
midnight of course on the fifteenth day
so these guys have been in there for 15
days no sleep on this experimental
stimulant gas yeah okay so finally they
said okay we're gonna end
experiment so they flush all the gas out
of the chamber and fill it back up with
fresh air now as soon as they do that
there are all these voices coming from
inside the guys that are in there
freaking the [ __ ] out okay you know what
do you put the gas back in here yeah I
know what I mean
turn the gas back on so they open the
chamber and the soleus there's a bunch
of soldiers and they go in to see what
the [ __ ] is going on and they are
screaming and then the soldiers start
screaming because it's a [ __ ]
bloodbath in there okay one of the two
subjects is dead and he's laying there
and it looks as though he has had chunks
of flesh like torn out of his thighs and
his chest and stuff and these chunks of
flesh are stuffed into the drain that's
in the floor so there's like water and
blood and stuff like four inches on the
floor of the cell now also they the food
rations that are in there only the first
five days of the food rations were eaten
residents ologist the rest of it's all
just sitting there and is food food
right so the four guys that were still
alive also had a bunch of chunks torn
out of their flesh and apparently had
been eating them and may have done it to
themselves because the their fingertips
were like bent down to the bone right
and you know they could I guess they
could tell from the angle or something
like that so it says in the story so
they have evidently been tearing out
chunks of their own flesh yeah and
eating them all right but that's not the
best part the best part is that the four
guys that are still alive not only did
they have all these chunks taken out of
their arms and [ __ ] like that
but they have opened up their abdomens
and taken their organs out like the
organs are still attached yeah but
they're just like laying there on the
floor in this bloody shitty four inches
of water and all of their organs are
just like laying outside of them like
all fanned out but they're still working
and [ __ ] like you
still see their stomach - dessert and
[ __ ] like that and all of these guys are
still like freaking out and screaming
telling telling them to turn the gas
back on okay right that gas is Flocka so
it's okay so the soldiers go in there
and they're trying to take these guys
out of the cell and the guys even though
all of their guts are hanging out and
they have like all the blood loss and
everything like that they are adamant
that they do not want to be taken out of
the cell right so they're just like
flipping out so one of the soldiers that
comes in like one of the test subjects
rips his throat out yeah right with his
bare hands another one has his testicles
ripped off and like a chunk bitten out
of his thigh or so like that like one of
these test subjects and so evidently
five of the soldiers died not at the
scene but I think some of them committed
suicide later or something like that and
then one of the guys one of the test
subjects okay his spleen which is
presumably sitting outside of his body I
guess during the struggle like somebody
stepped on it or it got ruptured or
something like that and this guy starts
to bleed out but he doesn't die yeah
right so they're trying to like sedate
them and take them out and everything
like that
they gave him evidently this guy with
the busted spleen was injected with more
than ten times the dose of morphine that
it should have taken to put him to sleep
and he was still awake and he was still
fighting and everything like that he
evidently was strong enough to break the
ribs and the arm of one of the doctors
that was trying to sedate him his
heartbeat for a full two minutes after
he had bled out okay okay without any
blood without any blood there was more
air in his system than blood even after
his heart stopped
he continued to scream for another three
minutes it's just trying to attack the
people around em too much detail right
I'm just saying yeah and he just kept
saying
more and more more MORE he's saying and
then finally he died so there are three
guys left still alive of the test
subjects so they restrained all of them
and they took them to a medical facility
I'm assuming it's a different place and
one of these guys was the guy with the
shorted vocal cords but the other two
could still talk so the other two were
still begging to you know go back in the
cell and have get the gas put back on so
the one guy that was the most [ __ ] up
the I mean of all the fucked-up business
that was going on they take him to the
operating room and they're gonna do
surgery to put all his organs back where
they go and you know kind of stitch the
skin that he had left like back over the
abdomen so that's what they're trying to
do and so they try to give him a
sedative it doesn't work he's like
starts fighting against the restraints
and then they bring out the anaesthetic
gas they're gonna put him under and he
flips out you do not want to want that
he does not want to sleep he doesn't
want to do any of that [ __ ] okay so he
tears like most of the way out of the
restraints then they finally you know
all of these guys jump on him and get
him they restrain him and stuff and they
put the anaesthetic mask over him to put
him to sleep and the instant he falls
asleep yeah he dies okay okay no I'm not
buying this no I know well like I said
I'm just telling the story I tell story
so it says that his after he was dead
they found out that his blood had
tripled the normal level of oxygen the
muscles that were still attached to his
skeleton because I guess a lot of them
weren't
we're torn he had broken nine bones and
his struggle to not be subdued now this
the second guy that they tried to work
on he was the one that had his vocal
cords shredded so he couldn't object to
the surgery he was just kept shaking his
head and shaking his head when they
tried to give him the anaesthetic gas so
they asked him well okay well do you
want us to do the surgery without the
anesthetic and he said yes so they did
the surgery on this guy with no
anesthetic he did not moan he didn't in
a pair
he was smiling hold on senators that she
kept then he kept like smiling at her
she looked at him like this is a very
creative tape yeah so you know they're
saying yes it was medically impossible
for this person to still be alive and
yet he was still alive so then the
surgery ends you know they put all the
best parts back and they were supposed
to go and so the guy starts trying to
talk like he needs to say something very
urgently and he couldn't talk as his
vocal cords were threaded from all the
screaming so the doctor hands him a pad
and pencil and he writes keep cutting
cuz it [ __ ] was hardcore right yeah so
the same thing happened with the other
guy you know he also refused the
anesthetic so they had to do the surgery
the the gun putting back in surgery with
that anesthetic and apparently they
super enjoyed it and they tried to give
actually one of them I think they had to
give a paralytic so he wouldn't move
around like while they were doing it and
they said but it didn't work for that
long like it wore off really quick and
then they just started fighting again
and [ __ ] like that and so then it says
the researchers tried asking why they
had injured themselves in this way why
they'd ripped out their own and donal
organs and whatnot why they wanted to
give be given the gas all the guy would
say because they asked us to one of the
guys and he said I must remain awake
that's all he said all right ok so after
this you know after their guts were put
back in the ones that were still alive
they said ok well just put them back in
the cell for now we don't know what
we're gonna do with them so there was
some argument you know some of the
research like maybe you should just
euthanize them cuz look at him for
Christ's sake meanwhile one of the
military guys who had guess is supposed
to be ex-kgb or something was like no
this is really interesting let's see how
this plays out don't kill them and stuff
like that so there's all this argument
and eventually the military guy wins
right so they put him back in the cell
and then they say they're gonna put him
back on the gas and what happens so
evidently the subjects that were
remaining they were connected to an EEG
monitor had their restraints padded they
were going to put
you know they had them restrained and
they put them back in the cell like
still strapped to their beds yeah now as
soon as they found out that they were
going to be put back in the cell and
back on the gas they all stopped
struggling okay right so there's like
hooray
that's what we wanted they said but at
this point you know this was 15 16 17
days or whatever and they said now at
this point it was it was starting to
become clear that they were really
struggling to stay awake right so you
know they said one of the guys was like
humming to himself like he was trying to
keep himself awake and [ __ ] like that
now one of the guys he was hooked up to
the EEG and they said that he would
flatline and then come back and flatline
and then come back and he was like
Wiggin out like if like every time he
fell asleep he was dying really so the
one guy eventually lost the struggle he
fell asleep and immediately died okay so
I'm thinking at this point this is where
the story gets a little confusing now
this is the most famous version of this
I've seen like a couple different
variations of it but this one says so
there's only two guys left alive to the
subjects so so the commander gave the
order to seal the chamber with both
subjects inside as well as three
researchers I'm not sure why that was
done but the three researchers are gonna
be locked up in here with these two guys
one of the three researchers evidently
pulls out his gun and shot the commander
I was like you were not closing me in
here with these [ __ ] right he
then turned the gun on the one subject
that was still alive that couldn't talk
the one that said it broke or just shot
that one as well so now there's only one
test subject left so the researcher then
evidently and this is where you know
that it's a fictional story right
through it so he turns the gun on the
last remaining test subject and says you
know I won't be locked in here with
these things yeah and then he turns the
guy he says what are you alright what
year is this supposed to be again in the
40s now yeah and this is what the guy
says it says the subject smiled and the
guy says have you forgotten so easily we
are you we are the madness that lurks
within you all begging to be free at
every moment in your deepest animal mind
we are what you hide from in your beds
yeah we are what you sedate into silence
and paralysis when you go to the
nocturnal Haven where we cannot read who
talks like that nobody but apparently
that's yeah this is trolling evidently
well it's not trolling I'm so I'll get
it so evidently so then the research was
like okay [ __ ] that so he kills the last
guy yeah and the last thing that the
test subject said was so nearly free
okay I ain't buying that word other now
is well this is what kills me obviously
this is a fictional horror story that
someone broke as a fictional horse yeah
now I don't know I mean I kind of know
why some people think it might have
happened but when you get to the end
like it almost sounds plausible at the
beginning like that kind of sounds like
an experiment they might have done back
then maybe kind of an ethical one but as
the details go on and I mean there's
just no way right that that should
happen the way it happened so if you
check out like all your you know
skeptical websites that look into this
urban legend kind of stuff Snopes
skeptoid stuff like that
the earliest instance of this story was
from August 2010 and it was originally
posted as a creepypasta which you know
everyone knows what a creepypasta is so
it was I don't think it was intended to
be a real story I came across about 2013
on YouTube well that's kind of when it
took off yeah I got about five minutes
into it I went yeah no even though it
had been around for a few years like I
said now the earliest one that he was
found now some people have said that a
version of it also appeared on on the
paranormal section of 4chan sometimes
it's titled orange soda yeah which I'm
not sure why I don't know if that's like
the handle of the first person that
posted it or or what not it might have
been so there are some variations of it
going around the internet some of the
variations name the gas that these
people were supposedly experimenting
called Nikolaev gas is usually what it's
called but on the lie of gas yeah so
like I said the earliest iteration of
this story appeared as a creepypasta
just like Slenderman
like Jeff the killer all your famous
it's probably one of the easily one of
the top five yeah best-known creepy
bosses and it actually came out of I
believe it actually came out of a
photograph okay that and it's a very
famous photograph I'll put it in the in
the video of like this really creepy
looking dude that looks kind of like a
mummy or he's I said yeah oh it's not a
hospital bed yeah yeah no that
photograph yeah which is you're gonna
laugh at this that photograph is
actually a Halloween prop okay um I
can't remember what it's called right
now but they sell it at Halloween super
stores and stuff like that
and someone had taken a picture of it
yeah on this bed and somebody like
photoshopped it to sort of look like a
real person and somebody kind of wrote a
story based around it or made the
picture like to go with the story or
whatever it's kind of hard to say but
I've always been kind of fascinated by
urban legends how they start yeah like I
said it seems like this one if it had
just been you know the first part of it
you could almost kind of believe that
because the Russians were doing some
weird [ __ ] right there was a very famous
experiment which evidently really
happened because some real scientists
like JBS Haldane and stuff like that
like said that they saw it and you know
were advocating for it and stuff like
that but if you go on youtube there is a
old video from 1940 called experiments
in the revival of organisms yeah we're
from the Soviet Union and apparently
they have this kind of it's like a blood
recirculating yet recirculating machine
they were you call it Auto ejector
yeah and it places the the heart and the
the lungs and they're using it to keep a
dog head oh yeah it's good bad it's yeah
I mean I can see why that would be
useful I don't know why they did that to
a higher animal but why would they do it
to a dog yes so it's a little hard to
watch um but it is in the public domain
so you can watch it yeah if you want to
but so I think that's why this story
seems believable at the outset because
there was some [ __ ] up yeah [ __ ] going
on they were also transplanting uh dog
heads onto other dogs so dog to making
two-headed dogs yeah and you know the
doctor that did they I don't think there
was a Russian that did that well yeah
maybe it was it's been a long time I'm
just thinking about it off the top of my
head I know that the guy who made the
two-headed dog his buddy looked at that
[ __ ] and said man don't you [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] again you know well yeah you
shouldn't even have to tell don't make
it two headed dog I mean that seems just
like super obvious yeah really yeah just
you know they want to know about tissue
rejection and things like that you know
like I said that is a noble goal where
I'm sure that that would be you know
useful information to have yeah it's
just how doctors buddy called [ __ ]
on that said man don't do that yeah you
know you should not tell me hey they
knew that's not keep a dog head alive
with the sheen that's [ __ ] up you know
what I'm saying but yeah so it's
interesting that you said that you first
heard this story in about 2013 that
seems when it went from just a fictional
horror story to urban legends yes where
must went viral or I wouldn't have found
around that's how I wasn't looking for
it and like I said it is easily one of
the best-known creepypastas if you
search for I mean I think Slenderman is
probably the best known one and Jeff the
killer might be better news I got a few
paragraphs into it that way nah this is
yeah there's just there's no way and it
should be noted to like not only with
the people like I said the experimental
protocol even if it was an unethical
experiment which they did do unethical
experiments okay fair enough but even if
they were really trying to determine the
effects of sleep deprivation the effects
of this particular experimental drug you
know why would they have let these
subjects stay in this room unobserved
for such a long time I mean obviously
that is a fictional trope because then
it's shocking when they go in there and
they find these people all [ __ ] up
with their guts hanging out and stuff
like that in a real experiment you would
want them to be under observation
constantly because you would want to
keep monitor and there'd be a goal to it
right and
you know even some of the worst human
experiments that we know of we're stuff
stuff that happened in concentration
camps you know and even those kind of
had the goal of trying to find out the
limits of human endurance in terms of
how long does it take for a person to
freeze to death in water yeah and they
wanted to know that because they wanted
to know when to call off an aerial
search of a downed pilot in the English
Channel that they you know yeah I mean
[ __ ] up isn't what yeah they did have
a region have a reason they're there
like there was a question that they want
yeah they wanted to know well if the
waters 25 degrees how long does it take
to kill the person so we all know when
to call up a search they didn't want to
waste gas in time looking for a guy
who's dead right that was the idea and
with something like this there's no
discernible goal why would you need to
know that yeah and another thing too is
that evidently these guys went without
sleep for 1516 days and we're eating out
their own and you know guts and eating
their own flesh and stuff like we went
further with that's what I was just
gonna say that's not very long yeah
there haven't been a [ __ ] ton of sleep
deprivation experiments alright there
was one done in 1964 it was actually
done as a science fair project but it
was monitored by Stanford a guy from
Stanford who was asleep researcher and
stuff like that a guy went 11 days yeah
experienced what you would normally
think if he was irritable paranoia
things of that elucidation things of
that nature
he went 11 days and after the experiment
was over he slept for 14 hours and after
that was totally fine he did not exhibit
anything like the sort of extreme
behavior now it should be noted that up
until now the Guinness Book of World
Records they don't do this anymore
because you know you've dangerous you
can't actually die from not sleeping but
the world record at this point before
they retired the classification is held
by a woman in England who did it in 1977
and she stayed awake for almost 19 days
and like I said experienced various you
know side effects yeah there's nothing
but nothing
terribly extreme yeah so the the fact
that these people would go that crazy
yeah you can't that short of a time yeah
it's not plausible yeah if you if you
went like four days without sleep
you probably don't feel too different
between four days and 14 days that
probably feels about the same yeah I
mean you would think you would get to
just like a base level of shittiness and
actually not getting and I mean like I
said I've been I think the longest I
went without sleep was two and a half
days yeah and you do start having mild
hallucinations at that point I actually
saw train going across the highway but I
knew it was a hallucination I was in the
army the same thing happened but it
actually the hallucinations happen even
sooner if you if you combine that with
like strenuous activity in really low
temperatures you know I mean you can
start to hallucinate just in 20 hours
yeah but the fact that someone would
start eating their own organs up see cuz
I think the point of this story it
seemed to go supernatural at the end
because like I said not only with these
dudes be dead and if that really
happened to them I mean just the blood
loss alone would have told them
obviously it almost seems like they were
using sleep deprivation combined with
this particular imaginary stimulant gas
to say that they almost went into some
other dimension or they access some
other otherworldly type of power or some
of it because they're apparently super
strong and you know stuff like that
which obviously okay so it sounds like
somebody exaggerated what they heard
about say like methamphetamine and bath
salts or what we know it's lockup
remember this guy here in Florida ate
the other guy yeah yeah guy naked down
the middle of traffic and one ate the
others face and then the cop shot him
I mean drugs can make you do bizarre
[ __ ] yeah but I don't think what they're
describing here was a sleep deprivation
and stimulant gas if it was if the gas
was that bad would happen pretty quickly
and then he would end the experiment and
it should be noted too that yes there
are gases that cause you know that are
stimulants and things like that
but if you keep administering it if you
yeah well it wouldn't
kill you or it would wear off you know
because the effect of a drug only goes
so far and then it's not effective
anymore yeah and you know the same thing
happens there now like I said I've
always been fascinated by urban legends
where they start because a lot of them
do have roots in something that really
happened and then we're later
exaggerated and you know over the years
and stuff like that this one like I said
seems to have been inspired by the
similar kind of experiments that the
Russians were doing and maybe even that
the Nazis were doing too and just kind
of taken to an almost supernatural
extreme now something that I found
really interesting is that I was reading
this article about it about this
particular creepypasta and the woman
that wrote the article or she had done
kind of a study of the most popular or
most viral stories from creepypasta and
she kind of analyzed what it was that
made them so popular like what
percentage of them had this thing going
on and stuff like that and she
discovered that she took like the 72
most popular ones and she said by far
the most popular stories 71% of them
concerned some type of unexplained
phenomenon ghosts aliens unknown
cryptids things like that so people
really loved the unknown so that was by
far the most common trope in the stories
that went viral 68% of them were
first-person narratives you know people
describing something so it sounded
plausible like it happened to me
61% of them were monsters or
supernatural beings 53% of them had
cliffhanger endings which you know
because people can debate them and you
know stuff like that
46% of them contained the murder of
course yeah because every the stakes
everyone's scared of that 24 percent of
them contained creepy images and like I
said some of them will Slenderman very
famously the whole urban legend of
Slender Man just grew out of Photoshop
somebody had made right it was like some
kind of contest where it's just take a
normal photo and put something super
creepy and so somebody put like this
really tall guy with no face
kind of put them in the background of
all the star to story and it whole and
it started whole and eventually a whole
urban legend grew up about it so it was
very um they've actually studied where
that came from so they know exactly
where that came from I guarantee your
religions start that way too well that's
all everything starts like that all our
been legends start like that
and six percent of them contain creepy
videos they said no usually a lot of
them have videos and I've even seen you
know photos and videos that purport to
be from the Russian sleep experiment
they said but usually most of these
videos are made afterwards by like fans
of the story it's very funny because I
don't know if people kind of put these
photos along with these stories later on
like genuinely thinking that that's what
they are because I've seen some photos
I've seen associated with the Russian
sleep experiment story are obviously
stills from movies I mean I've seen like
I was looking at like I was reading one
article or something about it and it had
a picture and I said that's from The
Machinist with Christian Bale the movie
where he lost like a whole bunch of
weight and he looks like a like a really
skinny and gross and I said that's from
that movie because I've seen it yeah
he's next row yeah not that but that was
a different one but oh and also another
one and actually I've seen stills from
the 1991 movie begotten which is like an
experimental silent film there's very
very famous images at the beginning of
this figure that's supposed to be God
and really creepy looking he has this
big long mouth and oh my god yeah he's
all like eviscerated and stuff that's
from a movie called begotten and I've
seen that illustrating a [ __ ] ton of
it's what it's weird yeah I don't know
if you'd like it it's a silent film yeah
it was made in the 90s but it's made to
look like one from the 20s like it's all
karate and [ __ ] up India and it's kind
of tells the biblical Genesis story sort
of but there's like there's rape and if
it's disturbing but it's very
nightmarish right but yeah like you were
saying before I think that one popular
video that made the rounds as like a
quote-unquote real creature sighting and
I don't know if you guys have seen it
but it's this it's this little creature
with like backwards legs yeah and he's
like kind of crawling into a road like
yeah and people are like oh my god
really
I'm like no that's from the movie extra
yeah it's like an alien movie mr.
British it's it's not very well known so
I could see why people get away with you
that kind of [ __ ] cuz maybe not a lot of
people saying yeah it's a movie it's
called Extro it's like a horror sci-fi
and I see that a lot yeah like
especially if if you kind of go through
YouTube and it's like the paranormal
stuff and the monster sightings and
stuff nine times out of ten most of
that's from like some obscure horror
movie or something like that and I don't
know if people are doing that that well
the first person that did probably doing
it deliberately but I think some people
are just like repeating it they haven't
seen that movie so they don't know right
that it's not and you don't know the age
of the poster then the person posted
this might be fourteen or fifteen years
old and like I said that one the one
with extra I can see how that happened
because you know not a lot of people saw
that movie but if you see that movie
because the first time because I had
never seen it and then you recommended
it and we wanted at one Halloween I
think and when I saw that yeah and when
I saw that scene I'm like oh my god I've
seen that on YouTube so many times this
length look at this freaky creature that
like it's a real cryptid I'm like now
that's just for a movie but yeah same
thing happened here like in that you
know I've seen a lot of kind of fake
pictures illustrating this particular
story but yeah so I'm gonna say it's an
awesome story and I should say too that
somebody made a half an hour long short
film it's called the Russian sleep
experiment official film and it's
available on YouTube they put it up
there and it's actually pretty good is
it there's only three guys it's not five
guys and some of the world growth stuff
is left out which I kind of thought was
kind of disappointing maybe they didn't
maybe they couldn't afford to do this
but it'll affect but it's it's actually
pretty good it's pretty good atmospheric
and stuff like that so I'll put a link
in the description if you want to watch
it cuz I kind of enjoyed it but yeah
just a story that's all it is then
really happen so that'll do it for this
first episode of 2018 yeah I can't
believe I know we got more folks to come
we're all getting old yeah hopefully we
will even have more more episodes this
year and like I said keep sending in
your suggestions for topics I have a
huge list but you know we can always add
more and also keep an eye out for our
latest movie reviews our last one was
to say and then we're gonna do more
coming up in the coming weeks and don't
forget to check out my book the faceless
villain if you haven't already check out
our patreon at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or go to our blog at 13
o'clock podcast WordPress com and
there's a link in the sidebar
if you would like to give a one-time
PayPal donation that would be much
appreciated
also check out zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock if you want to buy some t-shirts
with our cool logo and some other
panicle artwork and we will see you next
Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]